let's talk about al gore who was the vp
under bill clinton he of course lost the
uh 2000
election to was that the 2000 election
yeah the 2000 election
to george w bush that was the florida
hanging chad
election where it went all the way up to
the supreme court well al gore
basically since he has been vice
president has done a bunch
of business things all sort of related
to the environment and most of them kind
of fail but he makes
a lot of money on them i'll get to some
of that in just a sec but just this
weekend
he showed up and he's trying to freak
people out on trump
and i will only color this to say look
at the tone of his skin for a guy who
doesn't like trump very much
he's going with the trump bronze take a
look i would say
please do the right thing acknowledge
reality
stop hurting this country stop
undermining
democracy honor the great and honorable
traditions of the united
states of america this cannot go on the
way it is now
i will i will point out pamela that it's
kind of a sideshow
and people are turning off to it now i
really think they're beginning to
and joe biden's popularity continues to
rise
look at what he's done in controlling
the pandemic
look at what he's done in facilitating
the incredible
economic resurgence with a very strong
climate plan going overseas and
really bringing the respect for the
united states
back up again after it sunk to a
historic
low during the previous four years for
reasons we
all understand man al gore what a
ridiculous
charlatan what a snake oil salesman that
guy is
uh just to tell you one thing that al
gore did after becoming vice president
al gore created a tv station called
current tv now you've probably never
heard of it
but basically he used all of his
governmental connections
to create this tv station and the real
value of a tv station it was a
progressive
really far left news network right i did
one or two shows as a guest
on the network actually way back when i
was i was a crazy lefty it's
all true it's true all of it um anyway
he created this cable channel and he
used
basically it's very difficult to get a
cable channel right you can't just be
like call up time warner be like i want
a tv channel
you got to have connections to do it so
he used all of his connections
in government to get this left-wing
network on cable so you know it gets on
verizon and it gets on
time warner spectrum or whatever it may
be whatever your local cable channel is
anyway
the channel existed for a couple of
years it was an abject
failure ratings failure lost a ton of
money
and then what did al gore do al gore
then sold the channel the worthless
channel for 500 million dollars
to the government of qatar he sold it to
al jazeera which is just the media wing
of the government
of qatar so by the way qatar can we
confirm this i believe it's the number
two
oil exporter on earth i think i'm right
about that we'll get the we'll get the
exact numbers on that in just a second
um glenn beck and the blaze tv actually
tried
to buy current tv now the thing is what
you're buying is not current tv meaning
the shows that are on current tv
or any of the talent that's on current
tv you just want the access right you
just want to be on the cable channels
and then you bring in all of your shows
you bring in all of your talent
all of your programming et cetera et
cetera so al gore
decided instead of selling his failed
channel
to glenn beck okay now obviously i love
glenn beck he doesn't have to sell it to
glenn beck he
can do whatever he wants as a private
person but he decided to sell it and
make
500 million dollars by selling it
to the number two oil exporter qatar
okay
uh i can't get total confirmation it's
number two oil exporter but
we know that uh we they export a lot of
oil
and al gore doesn't like oil right it's
a fossil fuel he's got a whole issue
with fossil fuels
so he's just the worst sort of charlatan
that there is he says a couple things in
there that are crazy so he's talking
about trump hurting democracy now again
these are the same people that for four
years
said that trump was a russian puppet and
hillary clinton saying the election was
illegitimate and 24 hours
a day for four years every day trying to
destroy trump that's what they were
doing okay fine trump's undermining
he's hurting democracy he's undermining
democracy people are turning
turning off i don't know an awful lot of
people watched our interview although
youtube obviously
uh suppressed it because it only has a
couple hundred thousand views
the audio podcast did really well they
have trouble uh
suppressing audio podcasts more a little
more information on qatar thanks
uh they have the world's third largest
proven natural gas reserve and it's
and is the second largest exporter of
natural gas
i would like to know more on the fossil
fuel side but they export a ton of stuff
like
and either way qatar they've got some
human rights problems i think i think
you get the point
okay um so he he did al gore actually
did the producers did you ever see the
play the broadway play the producers
they create a flop they realize that
creating a flop
actually will make you more money than
creating something successful that's
exactly what he did
with uh with current tv uh what else
does he say there
uh he says biden's popularity is on the
rise
i have no idea what he's talking about
right like what are you talking about
actually
i don't know anyone that didn't like
biden before that likes him now
the people that didn't like him actually
think he's more incompetent
and has you know sort of worse scrambled
egg brains than they thought
before i think most people see that now
and i would say plenty of people
uh that did vote for him are kind of
like this ain't right
so that was another one then he said the
economic resurgence thanks to joe biden
have you guys seen the economic
resurgence no conor
nope these guys haven't seen it and they
have jobs okay
uh they haven't seen it um and then uh
oh and then that the people overseas
this is the lefties always love this one
the people overseas like us more the
foreigners like us more the europeans
like us more
did you guys see the g7 biden was
wandering around
wandering no you're not getting a bonus
nice try i see what you did there
uh biden was wandering around like an
old man at an old age home
shuffling his feet babbling on confused
there are moments where he's just
completely freaking lost but they like
us more
maybe you're right actually on that gore
because now they know we've got this
you know half-wit puppet up there that
they can do whatever they want so that's
another one
and then of course yo you know we've
done more on climate we've done more on
climate
you know okay fine we've done more on
climate like no you know he got us back
into the paris climate accords the paris
climate accords as we've talked about
we're a non-binding agreement but this
is what lefties and progressives love
they love things that are just on a
piece of paper if you just do what i've
done throughout the show if you just
scribble things down
and you hand it to somebody they love
that oh you said something nice and you
put it on a piece of paper it must be a
thing
the paris climate accords which mostly
put the onus on america to do things and
pay into the system had no mechanism to
force any country
to do anything much less should do we
have any right
as americans to tell china and india you
know countries going through their
industrial revolutions do we have any
right to tell them what to do i thought
we're supposed to stay out of people's
business you know so anyway score is
just terrible
and and the fake tan thing the fake tan
thing can we put the video back up for
just like
three like we get like five here's five
seconds about look at this fake tag man
i would say please do the right thing
acknowledge reality
stop hurting this country stop
undermining dem
acknowledge reality you're white and
pasty man accept it